évidemment dans
ce cet instant et pardonnez-moi d'être
effectivement peut-être un peu plus long
que d'habitude jearais commencer par des
remerciements parce que cet événement
arrive après un long travail de
nombreuses équipes et rien n'aurait pu
se faire si nous n'avions pas été une
équipe à travailler à monter ce projet
qui nous réunit ce matin pour cette
première pierre alors je essayer de pas
en oublier c'est la difficulté donc je
vais commencer un peu dans l'ordre
chronologique des choses et la première
que je voudrais remercier et citer c'est
mon assistante Sonia Cadu qui est là
parce que il y a pas de projet qui
commence sur ce territoire sans à un
moment donné un un un tête à-tête entre
nous pour lancer une idée et voir
comment l'idée peut s'appliquer et
comment elle de son côté ça fait 12 ans
qu'elle fait ce travail à mes côtés on
met en pratique en pratique c'est
organiser des rencontres trouver les
interlocuteurs et ce travail là est pas
simple évidemment je voudrais citer
parce que le conseil municipal de
montsogen l'équipe sortante du précédent
mandat et l'équipe actuelle a été aussi
totalement investi sur ce projet et rien
ne se fait s'il n'y a pas une équipe
soudée autour d'un projet et là je
voudrais remercier les conseillers
municipaux de Mont parce que si on a pu
aller au rythme qui que cela s'est fait
bien évidemment l'équipe municipale en a
une grande responsabilité et c'est pour
nous tous une belle leçon parce que je
me répète mais c'est l'illustration que
un travail d'équipe pour un territoire
c'est ce qui permet au territoire de se
développer l'équipe elle a été aussi
administrative elle a été liée à au
conseil général à la
confiance du président Berto à la
confiance de l'ensemble de
l'administration Directeur Général des
Services Jean-Claude ncher et puis toute
l'équipe de la DGS qui
travaille depuis une dizaine d'années à
mes côtés au Conseil Général remercier
Christian Dubreuil directeur général
adjoint des solidarités remercier
Frédéric pierre directeur de la
Direction France famille Véronique genp
Marie Belin Mario andreodavid qui est
ici toute cette équipe a permis la
faisabilité du projet parce que là
encore
c'est un travail vous vous en doutez
important et à la DGS personne n'a de
phobie
administrative je voudrais remercier
ici la fondation qui s'appelait à
l'époque mouvement pour un village
d'enfant qui nous a reçu en avril
2012 avec cette idée et Marc était déjà
là Marc Chaban un clin d'œil à toi
l'idée de de convaincre la fondation de
s'installer dans la Vienne et finalement
installé dans une zone rurale ce qui
n'était pas encore dans les schémas de
la Fondation puisque les 10 premiers
villages sont dans des territoires qui
sont plus urbanisés ou en tout cas moins
ruraux que celui sur lequel nous avons
bonheur de vous accueillir ce matin et
donc il a fallu convaincre et je peux
être témoin que les choses ont été
faciles grâce à au directeur général
précédent et puis à Fong qui est arrivé
ici à Mont le 26 septembre 2012 discrè
mais efficacement puisque pratiquement 2
ans après nous en sommes à à cette
première pierre alors c'était un travail
permanent avec la Fondation président
Conquet nous a reçu aussi souvent dans
ses bureaux de la rue de Lisbonne à
Paris pour comprendre comment ici à
montsurgain voilà dans une commune
rurale du loup du nais et bien nous
pouvions avoir cette attache ou cette
envie de se lancer dans la protection de
l'enfance l'envie on la doit à notre ADN
et nous sommes un certain nombre de ce
côté-là avoir été élevé au côté du
Président monori nous a appris qu'il
fallait avoir des projet il nous a
appris qu'il fallait avoir de l'ambition
il nous a appris qu'il fallait voir loin
fallait les voir grand et que bien a que
le travail qui comptait et c'est
toujours avec le travail qu'on arrivait
à à développer des idées à faire vivre
des projets et donc cette la Vienne est
effectivement terire de projet on l'a
montré dans d'autres domaines et encore
après le président mon harie sous le
mandat d'Alain Foucher sous le mandat de
Claude Berto on continue à faire vivre
ses projets à investir pour le
territoire et c'est un petit peu grâce à
à tout ce qui nous av appris justement
nos collègues que nous avons pu au
Conseil Général faire voter une journée
évidemment qui compte et donc on se
rappelle le 22 décembre 2012 la création
d'une mec une maison d'enfants à
caractère social ici à
montsurgain alors ça fait le lien avec
de propos monsieur le Premier ministre
qui sont importants dans les débats qui
sont les nôtres aujourd'hui sur à quoi
sert un conseil général et bien rien que
ce dossier aujourd'hui nous nous fait
des liens et sur les politiques les
compétences et sur l'implication et le
rôle sur territoire d'un
conseil la compétence qui nous qui nous
réunit ce matin c'est la la protection
de
l'enfance comment voulez-vous que cette
compétence soit gérer autrement les
intercommunalités on a entendu par
d'autres structures par d'autres
collectivité alors que aujourd'hui
après bientôt 28 ans puisque les lois de
décentralisation nous concernant c'est
1986 bien on a commencé à avoir cette
compétence en lien avec les services du
procureur de la République avec
l'ensemble des travailleurs sociaux avec
l'ensemble des acteurs il y en a
beaucoup dans la salle qui travaillent
dans le monde de la protection de
l'enfance ça serait vraiment dommage de
casser ce qui marche bien et donc je
crois que mais Jean-Pierre affarin est
convaincu à la Foucher aussi la défense
des conseils généraux dans la vie du
quotidien des Français est
incontournable et c'est je suis content
d'avoir cette occasion de le rappeler
aujourd'hui puis l'autre exemple c'est
l'aménagement du
territoire s'il n'y a pas le Conseil
général il y a pas de vide dans le monde
rural la ruralité c'est 15 millions de
Français et on peut pas ignorer 15
français et aujourd'hui s'il y a ce type
de projet en milieu rural c'est parce
que le Conseil général à un moment donné
a dit on
s'intéresse bien évidemment au milieu
rural c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu aussi
ça a été initié sous le mandat d'un la
Fouché une politique pour les maisons de
santé avec faire venir des étudiants en
médecine sur le mil rural nous
avons dans le domaine de la solidarité
mené 7 schéma en 10ant se schém jamais
l'État ne ferait ça jamais des
collectivités plus plus grande ferait ça
et jamais des collectivités plus petites
l'image de nos communes ou nos
intercommunalités ne pourrait monter se
schéma dans le monde des solidarités
enfance personnes âgées autonomie
handicap action sociale
insertion un chiffre de chiffres pardon
avant d'en
conclure nous avons depuis 10 ans nous
représentons l'action sociale sur le
département 7000 emplois vous imaginez
le levier économique c'est sur
l'ensemble du territoire avec des
emplois non délocalisable ici ce village
d'enfant ça va être 42 emplois ce qui va
en faire le le deuxème employeur du du
canton et donc vous imaginez
l'importance l'autre chiffre parce que
j'entends parfois pendant la vie
heureusement que le budget social c'est
un puissant fond non le budget social
c'est une réalité économique avant tout
une réalité économique la masse
salariale qu'il génère sur l'ensemble du
département est supérieur au budget
social au conseil général et donc c'est
de la redistribution dans l'économie
locale et vous dire que voilà cette
politique qu'elle a elle est utile elle
est belle elle est importante mais elle
ne peut se faire que parce que les
conseils généraux depuis la
décentralisation depuis la première
vague des lois de fer depuis les lois
d'oût 2004 que nous devons à
jeanpierrefarin et bien les conseils
généraux ont pu avoir cette liberté de
mener des
projets sur l'ensemble du territoire
c'est un grand bonheur de vous
accueillir ici vous avez quand même la
plus belle vue du
Poitou je ne suis pas objectif je le
sais mais j'ai bien l'intention de
continuer comme ça vous êtes sur un
territoire qui s'appelle Les Roches donc
c'est quand même bien pour accueillir
aussi des enfants qui vont avoir droit à
une seconde vie c'est un territoire qui
est marqué par son histoire l'histoire
du Poitou elle est belle tout à l'heure
j'aurais j'exliquis au président Conquet
que Henri qui est venu ici avait essayé
sa fameuse phrase Paris vaut bien une
messe en disant monsurgen vaut bien une
messe et puis comme ça marché il l'a
tenté à Paris on connaitt la j donc vous
avez bien fait de venir depuis Paris
pour certains depuis le loup duunet pour
beaucoup d'autres c'est un bonheur
personnel de vous avoir ici un grand
merci ce moment n'aurait pas été aussi
privilégié si un seul d'entre vous nous
avait manqué merci
merci